Never fear.
Miki is here.
Hello everybody.
Hello, hello, hello, hello, hello.
How am I feeling?
I'm feeling okay.
My nose is a little bunny.
Um, uh...
And, uh...
Um...
Yeah.
But we're back with a more Half-Life 2.
What part are we on?
Four?
Yes.
I move my...
I move the game screen.
Four, we're on part four!
Yeah!
Oh, today might be a little more chill.
I am feeling a little icky.
And tomorrow I want to stream a lot.
Thank you so much for the podcast.
Thank you.
Yeah, we are in the prison area.
We just made it to prison, baby.
And, uh...
Yeah.
We just...
It shows this area, but we have been past this for quite some time.
I think this was like a super duper.
long chapter.
Zoopy, lopey.
Welcome to my book, chapter.
I cure.
Yeah, I'm gonna have to remember how to... Oh gosh.
I always have to remember.
There's so many more weapons now.
I don't know which buttons are what?
Two, three, five, seven.
Up, down, up, down.
A, B, start.
Are you in prison for being illegally cute?
No, I'm in prison.
for illegal crimes.
Death.
You know.
Yeah, I'm suddenly feeling so tired.
Well, maybe it's this, it's this calming like waves and the birds and the wind.
Even though this area was not calm at all, we got attacked by a big old flying thingy.
This ASMR is so nice though.
What if we just did this?
What if I just fell asleep?
Yeah, I have a dabbing stream.
We dead.
First, we thought about the chest.
Thank you!
Were they cute murders or caused by cuteness?
Murder can be cute.
Coin it.
Make that my trademark phrase.
about you yesterday no matthew don't be worried don't be worried thank you though look at it if i put my my cursor here it's like she's standing on the bridge don't do it binky don't do it uh no i'm okay uh i don't know suddenly it's really just been my throat but not like in the you like how my throat has been bad usually it's like a just like a uh I don't,
I don't, like, I can feel it swollen, you know, when you wake up, and I don't know, you know.
Spock!
Thank you so much for the 20 gift, thank you, and Cato Devil, welcome to membership, thank you!
Minky Cursor.
Someone posted it on Twitter.
Someone reposted it on Twitter, too.
I think if you asked somebody, they would know.
Drop Ted Gorgeous.
Oh my goodness, I think we're...
I think we're getting a little crazy, though.
Half-life, so 40 years.
45?
Ah, heart-stealing thief.
I've also been sneezing a lot today, so I hope I don't sneeze too much for you guys.
If at all.
Yeah, I sound like a sickie, don't I?
Oh, gosh.
I sound like a sickie.
But I think we should just get into it.
sand traps we were here in the prison oh gosh oh oh those are my guys oh oh the alarms are going off okay wait six
six okay six and my health is low okay um this is great i came in from over here.
You guys are kind of freaking me out, I'm not gonna lie.
Oh,
there's guys up there even!
Okay.
And then I can throw.
Oh my gosh, they're loud.
Keep turning them down.
Okay, well, we came in from over here.
We can...
Wow, they all grew back!
What's in here?
Nothing.
Oh.
Are you good?
My little babies.
And then, um, maybe I go over here.
Nope.
Maybe I go over...
Oh!
This looks more likely.
Get out of the way, babies!
Go, my babies!
Go!
Oh, my babies!
Oh!
Where were they shooting from me from?
It was even a mystery.
I think they got got, though.
Oh, never mind.
Just kidding.
They did not.
Get got.
I got an achievement.
Bug hunt.
Use the ant lions to kill 50 enemies.
Oh no.
Oh no, Babies!
Babies, we need to go!
Babies!
Babies, it's time to leave!
Oh my gosh, wait, do I have a...
This thing?
I have three.
Oh, wow, wow, wow!
I think I took them out?
No, I didn't.
Keep going, keep going!
Nice shooting.
Thank you.
Oh my gosh.
I need to help them.
Everything's happening all at once.
I'm scared.
I'm so scared.
Wait.
Why can't I get this guy?
Oh my
gosh.
Hi baby.
One single baby.
Everything's happened.
I just started.
Oh my gosh.
Ouchie.
Ouch.
I have no more app.
Oh, there's two of them.
What the hell?
When does there become two of them?
Okay, we need to go inside, babies.
It's time to leave.
Oh my gosh.
How do I get in there?
Okay.
Okay, we're fine.
Everything's okay.
Ah!
Shut the door!
Reload!
No, my babies!
They're dying one by one!
We're gonna quick save here, since I'm scared.
When heaven's divine!
Okay, okay.
Pass me, though, did you dirty by leaving you here?
She didn't know!
She couldn't have known!
Run, babies!
Babies, run!
Babies, we need to get out of here!
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch!
Holy hell!
I think I'm just supposed to run or something!
I don't know anymore!
AHHHHH!
What is that?
That's a man!
Okay.
Holy hell.
Just keep going, just keep going, just keep going!
Oh my god, oh my god, oh my god, oh my god, oh my god!
Nowhere is safe!
This
guy.
Wait, is this my rocket?
No, this is my grenade.
I have two!
Only two!
Oh my god, oh my god, oh my god, oh my god!
Oh, I died.
Okay, let's get this back out.
I have two?
I have two of them.
Oh my gosh.
Um, nice!
This is a little ins... I'm stuck on the door.
And I get stuck on my babies too.
Oh my gosh, I'm taking every freaking hit.
Did that take out one?
I hope so.
I sure hope so.
Wait, wrong thing!
No, I didn't!
Oh my god!
Go, my babies!
Go!
Run!
Grab them!
Eat them!
Oh, wait, there's health in here.
This is a safe zone.
This is safe.
I think.
I think this is safe.
Ah!
Ammo box.
Wait, I don't think I saw one.
Now I'm gonna save right here?
the ammo box in here?
Oh, upstairs, okay.
Oh, I'm trying, I'm trying to run.
Oh, okay, awesome.
Oh, this guy.
No, wait, ammo box upstairs.
Uh, uh, uh, I don't see it.
To my right.
Okay, okay, okay, thank you guys.
Select the...
Am I right?
Am I blocked?
Is it good?
Guys?
I just passed it.
Oh, I see it!
Ah, sorry.
I see it.
Okay.
Oh my god, there's no good place to hide.
Get
trapped on my babies!
Please, please more and more and more.
Ah shit.
I don't know if it hit.
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
Oh damn, I think you shot it down.
Gosh.
I'm gonna die!
I'm not gonna make it.
I'm not gonna make it for real.
Oh.
Okay, I know where it is now though, so I don't need to waste time with it, you know?
I know where it is, so I don't need to run around and be silly.
Okay, did they get those guys up there?
I'm running as
fast as I can!
Oh my gosh.
Holy shit.
Please hit.
I think that hit.
Somehow.
Somehow I think that hit.
Oh my god, I don't think that hit though.
It's going crazy.
Ah!
Did you see it?
Just be like...
Everywhere in those stuff.
I'm trying to make use of these guys to attack.
No, please.
Shotgun.
Oh my god, don't do that.
Why would you do that?
I wish, though, that it was safe in here, but it's not.
I wish I could run.
I wish I could run, but I can't.
Oh my gosh, ouch, ouch.
Please.
Take him out.
Ouch,
ouch.
Ouch.
Oh my god.
Okay, we got one.
Save.
Yeah, you're purring, you're purring, you're so happy.
Me too.
Is that more?
That's true.
Ah!
Somehow we did it.
What a start to the stream.
I know.
Really could have used the warning.
Coming up.
It's going to be a news.
wait there was definitely a body in there when i saw earlier maybe they killed him a different way oh it blew this up that's kind of fun
okay gg easy first try yeah that clear out your throat oh my eyes are so dry from just ducky thanks for the gifted let me i'm just gonna go around, make sure I didn't forget anything before we continue onwards.
Oh no, I was absolutely locked in.
Oh, there's there's C, C, C.
Wish I could find stuff for my suit.
Okay.
Ammo's always good.
Or, yeah, ammo's always good.
Oh.
This is not even used all the way.
I'm too good.
What are these sounds?
Where you lead, we will prevail.
Venser Amos, bug bus.
Oh, there was a grenade there.
Hidden.
Secret.
I'm hearing all sorts of noises.
Nothing here either.
Okay, we continue.
Continue onwards.
Ah.
Okay.
Wow, that was really exciting.
Wasn't it everyone?
This doesn't look so good.
My baby's gonna come in?
Deploy sterilizing.
Interceptive infection block.
A5, A7, B2.
Babies!
Are they gonna come in?
I need to call them.
How do I call them again?
I know I shake the ball.
Oh, like that.
I squeeze it.
I give it a good little squeeze.
Come on in, babies!
Bug boss!
Danya, thank you so much for nine months!
Minto is bug mommy now.
It's Matoru the papa.
Yeah!
Timura!
Thank you so much for the tag you have to thank you!
Okay, all right, now we're safe.
And we need to equip and...
Bug babies?
Can you come?
Ew, it's so squishy.
They're not coming with me.
I hear them out there.
My babies!
No!
Oh.
Nova Prospect.
I can't hear them all my babies i don't like this
okay thanks i guess it looks so spooky
oh is this a prison like is this the area of the prison i need to be in Sorry, stupid questions.
This is, this is like the prison part of the prison.
Sorry, I know what I'm saying.
I swear.
Maybe Brigade will come again?
Why are there dead people?
Gosh, I keep having to turn up and down the volume.
Just let me know if it's like a little too much sometimes.
Or too little.
You can say.
I'm scared!
I need to get in there.
Maybe?
I don't know if I want to be in there actually.
Hello, old man!
I'm looking for the girl's father, no?
I believe is the case here?
Looking for that girl's father.
None of these even have beds in them.
It sucks.
It's so scary.
I don't like it.
Oh!
Jail break!
This will be me.
Oh my gosh.
Oh!
You hear all this?
Sorry, I'm gonna be safe, scumming like crazy here, I feel.
Sorry.
I'm scared.
Oh?
Wait, was that a turret?
That's something we haven't had in these games at all as turrets.
It has to be, yeah.
I think it's killing little head crabs.
Did it get through?
Oh wow!
Wait, are those my babies?
No, sir!
Why are those my babies?
Do these things still get taken out by a...
By a shoddy?
My babies!
Can I open this?
Oh.
I'm just...
I just picked it up.
Oh, there's another one upstairs.
Oh, but I think it also just got shut down.
Babies?
They should come back, no?
My babies.
E works on turrets.
That's so...
I could just...
I could just pick them up.
Oh, there's more.
upstairs okay okay okay there's definitely more upstairs all right okay it's all right babies i'll get you i'll get them for you i'll get them for you somehow some way i'll reach you
my babies i need the parkour actually i'm not quite sure hello babe oh here we go hello babies Oh, my babies!
They missed me!
They missed me so much!
You hang tight!
Oh!
Who is that?
Oh, it's a turret from...
A turret with the best eyes in the world.
Oh, oh, we're here.
We're here.
Okay, I imagine there will probably be like something to unlock all the gates, right?
Like probably that?
Okay.
Oh, gosh.
Oh, wait.
Oh, no, this is a...
Okay.
Oh,
don't kill them.
They're sweet.
Wait, wait, wait.
That one's mine, right?
Did I burst that?
I like how you can just hear him walking away like a dog.
Is that mine?
Oh.
I think you'd recall.
I don't know.
There was one time I...
What was it?
It was a...
I read a story about like a koala in a zoo.
And koalas are not very bright.
The koala was given another baby to put on its back.
Like from a different koala, and he was just like, I guess that's mine.
Like, yeah, okay.
Sounds about right.
Wait, the big guy, that's not...
It's not going to be a problem, is it?
Do I have to have, like, shared ownership of my children?
Is that what we're doing now?
Uh, wait, gravity gun.
Which one is...
Uh, shoot.
There we go.
Oh, I just saw them right there.
Oh my god.
Oh, wait.
That would have been bad.
Had they been on?
Oh, gee.
That's right.
Thank you for the reminder.
Yes, I forgot that I can press G to just automatically switch to it.
Thank you.
Hmm.
shoot okay all good whoa the dentist what's been going on in here huh shoot what's been going on in here
oh no not press that
back to scary okay back to creepy back to spooky got it
Hold my hand.
What's in there?
What's in this water?
I know there's somebody.
Oh!
Oops.
I'm running.
Ah!
Something's picking me up.
Oh, good thing I completely noticed These guys.
Beforehand.
They're so gross.
Let's get the other guy.
Ah!
I got the other guy.
Let's get the third guy.
That's right.
Totally, totally planned.
Oh my gosh!
No!
More of them?
I think I got them.
I can't hear what she's saying.
Is it something about me?
Okay.
I save again.
My babies?
There should be more of my babies.
Where are they?
Okay, I can either park or...
Who's making that sound?
Where at?
Wait, I think I heard him.
We saw him?
No soup!
Oh!
Ow!
Okay.
Soup in here.
I guess I can go down.
But I'm scared too.
Because I got these guys before.
Yes, I did.
Yes, siri.
Where are my babies?
Nobody in here?
Not a single guy?
Does this prison even hold anybody?
Being so extra cautious because I'm scared, you guys.
I'm scared, right?
Please.
I thought that today was going to be a chill with my babies.
Can I get it?
Oh, there's two of them.
Oh!
Oh, okay, okay.
I got the memo.
I'll go down.
Or I could...
Um, let's see.
What else can I shoot at them?
Maybe I can grenade it.
No, well, what's up?
What else we got?
I can just...
Oops!
That was a waste.
Throw a barrel!
Wait, that's so smart!
Okay, close.
Close.
Okay.
I think I got him.
No, I didn't.
Come here, you.
Wait, I actually got one!
That's fun.
Okay, you, come here.
Woo!
That's exciting.
That's so fun, actually.
What's in there?
Oh, let's not have that as my thing.
Okay.
Okay, we got a lot going on.
A lot to check out and around and about.
So let's see.
What do we have in here?
Not quite anything, huh?
Okay.
Really?
Not even, like, supplies?
Nothing?
My babies?
Come from nowhere?
Yeah, I need to make use of the...
I think I use the gravity gun in, like, ways that seem too...
What's the word?
Like, too easy, in a way.
Need to be a little more creative with the gravity gun.
I like it.
Okay, left in here.
Where are my babies?
It's a great question.
I was looking around because I thought something was walking downstairs, but it was me tripping over that.
Oh, that's just to the lights.
Oh, hello.
Not through here.
Use a scientist's brain.
Okay.
Exactly.
Nothing over here?
There's no supplies at all around here.
It's kind of crazy.
The radiator heaters on the wall...
I didn't... I see I saw them, but I didn't know if I could take them off the wall.
Good to know.
Thank you.
Congrats on 101010.
Gokuchi, goku, goku, goku.
Raging 200k!
Wow!
Thank you!
Oh my gosh!
I didn't even know...
Tis!
Thank you, everybody.
Thank you, Nate.
Thank you.
I should have used my crowbar for him.
Not worth it.
Not worth the...
I saw even the box moving.
Who were you fooling?
Huh?
Who are you fooling?
Whoa.
It's quiet.
This looks like a boss area.
I feel like I just fought a boss with those two planes, though.
Wait, is this where they play B-ball?
Nice.
Good senses.
Yeah, I think.
It's just really...
Oh, no.
Oh, no, no.
I'm scared.
It's time for what?
Gravity gun is good in this fight.
Soup.
Be brave.
I don't know why I'm such a little baby today.
Oh, yeah.
Okay.
I'm just looking at what all the numbers and everything that I have what was this one again can't remember shotgun crossbow grab gun okay being a baby is a survival tactic I guess so okay
Assault rifle.
Oh, that's right.
Okay.
Let's go back to my shoddy and then grab gun and shoddy.
I'm just gonna be brave.
Let's go.
I'm one of you!
I'm one of you.
I'm one of you?
You like me.
No, you don't.
Oh, he broke my stov.
Oops, that's not what I meant to do.
Holy shit!
Ouch!
Holy moly!
Uh-oh.
Oh, we kind of like...
Oh.
Holy cow.
Uh, uh, come back, come back.
I gotta, like, get him off guard.
Oh my gosh.
Oh, I got him.
Nice.
Like, when he charges.
Oh, I was too early.
Oh, I don't know if that worked or not.
Ouch!
I couldn't run.
I was trying.
Oh, shit.
Wait, did I get him?
Woo!
First try?
Wait, you like me?
You like me, you like me.
Yippee!
Okay, I lost quite a bit, but there were some...
There was some, what's it called?
On the other side.
Grab gun for the win?
Wow.
Thank you to whoever suggested that.
Nice.
I got my babies back.
I got my babies back, back, back.
What's in here?
Would this be a little break from the guy?
Live custody battle.
Yeah, that's what I thought was gonna happen.
Oh, there's maybe over here.
Oh, dang, there were toilets.
I might be the greatest gamer of all time.
Guys?
Is this what the men's bathroom looks like?
Even when you poo, you have no doors?
It's kind of sad.
If you say so.
You make eye contact.
That was kind of fun.
You're never lonely, right?
I got to save all my shoddy ammo, too.
It was so good.
I'm guessing I go through here.
I don't see anything else, though, which is kind of sad.
Hello, baby.
The sinks are where we pee.
Oh, from above it really did look like basketball.
Okay.
I don't think there was anything else, sadly.
Hold on, I'm going to go look.
Competitive peeing.
I mean, I haven't not heard of that.
Okay, sorry.
I'm being a little greedy.
Looking for things.
Oh my gosh.
Even the bleachers.
She wears high heels.
I wear sneakers.
Cheers, cheer, captain, and I'm on the bleachers.
Oh!
Wait, you're my baby.
So, I'm so sorry.
You scared me!
No, okay.
What was reload the auto?
What was it?
sixes to save but i don't know what the reload is
f9 oh thank you okay don't yeah don't scare me like that
that's oh my gosh they keep trying to get me uh oh you hear that i heard what i heard a I hear radios.
Go, team, go!
Go, team, go?
Is it a turret or a guy?
Oh, no, it's one of these things.
I'm stuck.
I'm stuck, babies.
Hold on.
I need to take care of this thing.
Wait, can I gravity gun it?
Oh, okay.
All right, we need to gravity gun this thing.
I'll save you my babies!
Ow!
There's men too!
Don't throw that!
Wait, um, let's... this one.
Yeah, that's right.
Stunky.
Um...
Oh, there's more guys!
Use the allies to kill 50 enemies.
So yeah, baby.
Come on.
Oh!
Oh my gosh.
I'm trying to...
Oh, I don't even know what's happening here.
Oh, gosh.
Okay.
I have to go around.
This way.
Oh, that's me!
Don't shoot at me!
Ah!
Is there a guy in here?
Oh!
From where?
I don't see him.
Oh, it's a turret again.
Hello.
My babies!
Watch out.
Watch out, everybody.
I can't see anything.
Okay, we go in here.
How is Delta?
I hope you had a good time.
Oh, it's so much fun!
No, I think even the graphics, everything looks really good.
Yeah.
What's that sound?
Something's revving up.
What is that?
What's in?
What's...
I see something there?
What are they doing to him?
No!
What are you...
What are you guys doing to him?
Uh...
One second.
Is that our friend?
Oh!
No.
Our friend.
I think I got everything.
Let's just keep going.
I opened something.
Oh my gosh.
My babies.
I need to...
Okay.
I'll take the other door.
You're so right.
This is fine.
We'll just take the other way.
Okay.
I was hoping that would be...
Babies?
One moment.
Whoa.
What's happening to you?
It's turning into a heartless.
What just happened?
Who exploded?
Oh, come on!
I was gonna do this properly!
Oh my gosh.
Did you mean to do that?
Ow!
Go, babies!
Go!
You got this.
Oops.
I don't know why I thought that.
What is...
What is that?
Oh!
They'll handle it.
Is it downstairs?
No.
Hmm.
Oh, I see them in the door.
Haha!
All your friends are dying too.
Oh, come in.
Alright, get ready, my children.
Get ready, my children!
Did they...
He didn't even make a sound.
He just died.
Low HP, yeah, but there's no HP anywhere.
Oh, maybe here?
Ah, hi!
I lied.
There was HP right in front of me.
This whole time.
Wait, there we go, three.
I gotta remember three.
Anyway, that was easy.
Oh, wait.
The game is so kind.
Sometimes.
Sometimes the game is kind.
I thought that might be a little guy.
Okay, so...
Oh, wait.
It opened that door over there, right?
Okay, so...
Wait a second.
Watch out, babies.
Room with loot.
I saw it.
Nothing else.
Okay, nice.
Good job, team.
She found it.
Yeah, I have gamers.
sense I have gamer sense sometimes all right all right onwards is there anything up there doesn't look like it okay all right distracted babies oh wait no go and I'll go get it with my gun.
Oh, there's more.
Wait, there's way more.
Oh, my goodness.
There's a ton of them.
Oh.
There we go.
Oh, gosh.
It's a gamble.
Wait.
Oh, we broke it.
It's fine.
This thing's kind of heavy.
Okay.
All right.
Good job, team.
Come here and get your other friend.
Just kidding.
Come here.
Get your other friend.
Okay, team.
Oh, gosh.
There's a guy right there.
I didn't even know there was a third person.
Freaky.
Wait, how do I turn this off?
No.
I'm saving even though...
Oh, my babies would have taken care of them.
Wait, those aren't my babies.
babies?
Or...
Wait, that's a lot of them.
They're not coming to me.
Wait a second.
Uh-oh.
Take that.
Children!
My children.
Baby battle?
Uh...
I don't know why I've started using the SMG over my shotgun.
I don't know.
I just... I'm feeling it.
Um,
ah!
Go!
I don't know if they'll be able to.
Hold on, I'm gonna throw a grenade myself.
I don't think that made it far at all.
Wait, I heard something.
Is that one of mine?
Eli Vance, that's her dad, right?
No, don't touch it!
Don't touch it!
I just keep hearing guys, hold on.
I'm trying to, like, pay attention to the audio at the same time, though.
Wait, is that a guy, or...
There was a guy.
Or a turret.
Actually, I can't tell.
Guy on a turret.
Talking about me.
Terror?
Chaos?
Maybe?
No.
Couldn't have been, man.
Oops.
Too hard.
There we go.
Can someone give me TLDR?
Nothing in here?
Oh, I was like, what the heck?
It's my baby's leg clipping through the wall.
You're on the radio.
They're talking about you.
Bad guy says bad things.
They captured Alex's dad.
Yeah, that's why we're that's why we're here why did i do that um guys so sorry did i save i did not so sorry i wanted to hear soup and i thought i had the gravity gun on
i thought i was holding the gravity gun and i was like soup
Where is...
It's okay, we'll get through this easy.
Go, baby, go!
Yeah!
Nice.
And then another guy's gonna go up there, no?
Maybe not.
Oh, there he is.
Ouch!
I can't move when you're all here!
Go, my babies!
Go!
Go get his butt!
Oh!
Oh, wait.
I feel like I should just Cross blowing.
There we go.
That's way easier.
Okay, anyway.
There's- this guy is yapping.
He's saying so much.
Excuse me.
Soup.
Oh, you scared me.
Dang, did I only get one?
Aw, that sucks.
Dang.
It would have been a nice shot had I made it.
Oh, oh.
No, my babies, no!
Ouch, I'm low on HP.
Ouch, ouch.
Can I get more HP, please?
No, no, no, no.
Oh, shoot.
This thing is fine for you.
Where are you?
Where the heck?
You guys get it already?
You're so fast.
Excuse me.
You guys, my babies are better suited for outside.
Okay.
Okay, we're fine.
Whoa, we're not fine!
But actually, this is okay because I wanted to kind of redo this...
Oh, that's...
Okay, that's...
I wanted to kind of redo this part, so...
In the end...
That didn't work out so well.
Okay, actually, it was way better the first time.
Oh.
Guys!
Okay.
I'm still a little...
A little more HP than before, I suppose.
Holy cow.
Alright, now we know these guys come in.
Hmm, shoot.
Yeah.
Come on, come here!
There we go.
Oh, no?
Still going?
Oops, sorry.
He's fine.
Should
I save?
I'm not sure.
I'll save.
We'll get more health.
Hopefully, eventually.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Oh, my babies go.
I'm dying here.
Oh my god, I see another guy on the stinking thing.
Oh, shoot!
Yeah, I do need a medical attention.
Um...
Yeah, crossbow would probably be good here.
Okay.
I got him.
If I wouldn't be doing my duty as your administrator.
Please, help!
I hear more guys.
I almost want to save, but at the same time, I'm like, I don't think I should.
Nails.
What?
Health.
Tiny bit.
Okay, I'll save.
Go, my babies!
And everybody died.
Oh, there's more of them.
Okay, come on in.
Oh, yes.
Good job, team.
I helped.
Okay.
Maybe not the most great place to...
Okay, hold on.
Let's do...
Wee!
Watch out!
I'll also do that.
Oh.
There's nobody left!
I'm so head empty here.
Okay,
let's see what we...
No, no, my baby!
Stop!
Come here!
Actually, actually, oh, this door is open.
Okay, I didn't even notice it open or not.
Is there anything I can throw?
One moment!
Come here.
Babies.
My little children.
I love you so.
My little...
My little precious creatures.
Oh, I missed.
That's one way to do it.
Did I get hit from that?
I don't know if I took splash damage there, but whatever.
I did?
Minus three.
Ouch, yeah.
Oh, did I throw that?
Oh, watch out.
Aw.
Ouch, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, Please.
I'm like literally living on a dream.
Living on a prayer here.
Okay, thank you for the 10.
But I'll take it.
Some is better than none.
Where?
Oh, I'm just going up, up and up and up and up.
I have been asked to say a few words to the transhuman arm of sector 70 and Overwatch.
I saw them.
Concerning recent successes.
Containing members of the resistance, science team.
Does that even reach?
Can they get me?
Can I get them?
They're coming over?
Are they gonna run into that?
If I didn't pass along the message I have received from our benefactors, the capture of you advances in event of major significance, make no mistake.
Ugh!
Health!
And stuff!
Let's see.
Anything that I can throw.
Oops.
I didn't mean to shoot this again.
I clicked on the shotgun.
It worked.
I feel like I just wasted those, but whatever.
Stop.
Wait.
Babies, one moment.
Babies, babies, babies!
I can't see you when you're in my way!
Please, come here!
Stay, stay!
Love the bouncy ball of death?
Did I get it?
No.
I'm just gonna take it.
It's okay.
I just saved right here.
Let's see.
I'll just throw a grenade and instead then.
Yes?
Good job, babies!
Obviously, I am not on the ground to closely command or second guess the dedicated forces of the Overwatch.
But this does not mean I can sure...
Uh-oh.
Here they come.
come.
Uh-oh, here they come.
Oh,
there they go.
Just kidding.
Okay, what's going on here?
What is that?
How is it possible?
This is not some agent provocateur or...
Provocateur.
A stalker.
Oh, they're making more of these guys I have good reason to believe that in the intervening years he was in a state that precluded further development of covert skills the man you have consistently failed to slow let alone capture freaky standards simply that an ordinary man how can I fail to apprehend him okay well all right I believe the upgrade else no and they just stuck this guy in a closet so sad prove themselves an indispensable augmentation to the combine overwatch they will have to earn yeah they come
is total extinction in union with all the other unworthy branches of the species Let's not allow it to come to that.
To convince our benefactors that you are the finest in species.
It's just so easy.
Hold on, I'm going to see if they have anything.
Yes, indeedy.
Oh, yeah, baby.
Okay, nice.
My children.
My children, please.
Okay.
Look at that guy laying down over there.
Lying on the job.
Well, they give me quite a bit of supplies here now, don't they?
Curious.
Lazy bones.
Dr. Bree, that was the first meet over.
Okay.
Are we gonna be fighting the mother again?
No?
Oh.
Okay, finally he shut up.
Oh, finally.
More health?
Is that to me?
Is that right now?
Is that...
I don't
know where I am.
Here they come!
No!
I'm gonna go get them first!
It's really quiet all of a sudden, though.
Oh, wait.
This is the one.
They did take out the other queen.
Nice.
Oh!
Oh, come on.
When I press throw, it doesn't always register.
Oh!
Stop!
Nice.
Good job, team.
I'm not even Well, I'll grab the rest of the health I'm not gonna say though Because that was kind of messy
Good job team We're a team We're the best to ever do it Okay, even I know when I'm lying I
saw it There Nope
Okay, they'll stop noticing and go I don't know if I got any of them I didn't okay wait I can run into this room I probably
should have run when they didn't notice me but it is what it is you don't know where you are you are here for now for the brain all I think about is Neil
babe oh whoa I
don't have him
I do have him
okay yeah yeah oh shoot shouldn't have reloaded my silly goose
Wow, one bullet left.
Oh, that was...
Where are my babies?
Why aren't you doing more, huh?
Oh, was that guy, like, on the ground?
Oh, no, they're getting the babies.
Speak and they shall be summoned.
I know I saw a guy.
Oops.
Ha ha ha ha.
Hi.
Yeah, get his butt.
Oh, there's another!
Oh my gosh.
Uh-oh.
Why is there?
Suddenly scary.
Woo!
Wait!
I've tried to...
There we go.
Just trying to switch my gun.
I'm panicking.
Where'd the turret go?
Disappear?
I got knocked down somehow?
Oh, there it is.
Okay.
I am half-life.
She said it!
The game!
There was one here.
How did that get all the way?
Did I do that somehow?
Maybe this trick shot and hit it?
I might be better than I thought, you guys.
That might be better than I thought.
I think it was all mean.
I'm taking the credit.
Okay, wait.
Before we go this way.
Watch is up here.
Huh?
I hear it.
But where?
This...
Calm down, calm down.
I think he got me.
No, it wasn't behind me, for sure.
Nothing else.
There's blood.
Okay, I think that's probably the way we have to go.
But I want to see and hear real quick.
I can't tell.
Oh gosh, there's a lot of...
blood oh no no please no no no no oh snazzy hate hate hate hate hate abuser dead imminent that's not good
i know there were more any more
banner I don't know where it is.
My ox!
I don't have it.
Oh, there it is.
Come here.
Good enough.
Ah!
Oh, I hear it.
Nope.
Where are you?
I hear it.
There it is.
Is he dead?
He's dead now.
Okay!
Oh!
Yeah, I double shot these guys.
I don't want to take any risk.
I don't care.
I'm not taking the risk.
High voltage.
I don't care!
Mint is sorry.
No, I'm not.
nothing in here just a nat i should have never gone well actually there was more health and stuff down here so i guess it's fine i guess it's fine okay all right so we explored around here we're g2g good to go hello baby dead baby
That's a lot of blood.
I don't know.
Humans have a lot of blood, I think.
Like, surprisingly.
What was that?
Did I see something crawling?
Oh, come on.
Oh.
Oh, watch out!
Watch out, team!
Are we good?
not good
oh my gosh babies babies I need your help babies I went in blasting babies I'm in trouble
babies I went in blasting
babies I didn't mean to babies it just happened and I started getting really oh my goodness getting into some hot stuff.
It was bad.
It was not good.
I don't know where I am.
Oh my gosh.
That's evil.
What the hell is this room?
Okay.
Where the...
Where did you come from?
Oh.
Alright, cool.
Oh my gosh.
There's turrets everywhere.
Literally everywhere.
Can I not...
Wait, I can shoot in here because they...
Oh gosh, they can shoot in here.
I was going to say the gas looks like if you shoot, it'll explode.
Babies, I need you to not do that.
Ah!
I'm gonna die here.
No, please.
Ah, I'm stuck on these freaking bugs.
Ah!
I'm just trying to get an idea of how to get in there.
What to do?
Oh.
Okay, there's one down.
She's a grenade.
Can I try to save them?
I try to save them for guys.
But, you know.
I guess When there's this many Because it only takes out like one I don't think that hit it Nope That's really annoying
Yeah I guess I was right About the gas
It would have been great If I still had turrets over there I think Oh
I'm gonna try one more time with the grab gun.
Invincible!
Oh my god!
Will you guys die so it stops?
Go away!
Oh my gosh!
Let me try another barrel.
Oh!
Please move!
My aim.
They're just all gonna die.
Yeah, I don't think that was worth it, but whatever.
Whatever.
Whatever!
Oh, there's like actual guys in here?
What?
I don't know.
Oh, it's that one I'm hearing.
Okay.
I'm just gonna save because I don't feel like doing all this over again.
Um, okay.
Oop, oop, oop.
Oh.
Wait, I didn't mean to actually do that, but that's funny.
Um, what can I throw?
Anything?
Wait, can I grab you?
Come on, come on.
Come here.
Can I get...
Wait, did that work?
Oh, it did!
Oh my gosh, it did!
I got him just enough!
Ha!
Nice.
Okay, cool.
Let's keep going.
Train?
That didn't sound good.
Oh.
Wait, I'll do this one.
Oh, my gosh.
They were so ready for me.
Oh, Oh, I'm going to die.
I'm going to die for real.
Where did he go?
I know he didn't die.
Wait, did he?
Oh, maybe it did.
Oh.
How did I die?
I don't want to be shooting.
And look at all this.
Uh oh.
What's all this for?
Who is shooting anyway?
invisible guns invisible invisible everything
wait let's just have my shot at that now
oh her again wait where is she oh
I don't know if that got her oh
uh uh Wait, uh, uh...
Got her?
Please, please, please, no!
Ah, I have no!
Uh-oh, wait, this is gonna come down.
Wait, if I let her keep doing this, she's gonna all come down!
It's all gonna come down!
Wait, that doesn't pick up?
Okay, just kidding.
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch!
Where's all my stuff?
The throw!
Ouch!
Anything?
Please?
I'm gonna start shooting now.
Anyways, started blasting?
Ah!
Okay.
Eventually, eventually we got there.
Yippee!
Okay, doki.
Do I go this way?
Do I go where they came from?
Oh, I'm trapped, actually.
I'm trapped.
There we go.
Again.
Let's check out what was over here.
I did save, right?
Okay, I did save.
Oh, okay.
We definitely...
Wait, I'm last.
No.
Alright.
Reminds me of the day before that used fake gunfire to make people think there were players around.
Oh, like in multiplayer stuff?
Oh, good.
Okay, there was more ammo and stuff here too.
Okay, that's where we came from, so I think this is where we go.
Can't tell if chat is broken or not.
Are you guys alive?
Is the stream alive?
It's okay, I'm fine talking to myself.
I do it all the time.
My babies are gone, but...
My babies.
Awful.
Oh!
Is that guy alive?
I mean, he's dead, but he's dead alive.
Yeah.
Oh, boy.
We can still hear this, Minto.
We're still watching.
Chai is dead, dead.
Oh, thank you.
Okay.
I thought so.
I was like, wait a second.
I can hear you.
Okay.
Well, now it's just- now I feel alone and I'm a little bit even more nervous, but that's okay.
This is fine.
We persevere.
Why is everything- why is it like this?
Why is it all like crumbly?
Um, that doesn't seem good.
Things are real crumbly.
Wait, uh, uh, I think I need to stack here.
Oh my gosh, wait, I just ruined my chances of survival.
I think I need to go in here.
Ah!
Okay, uh, I can't tell if this is timed or not.
I'm just gonna keep running.
What a...
Entanglement.
Wait, did I just beat a chapter?
That one was pretty short.
compared to like last last one
I'm scared not having you guys backseat me don't feel lonely now Chad is dead just like you no it's funny sometimes certain games like that I mean I know this game is so old so there's gonna be like lots of people that have played it a lot and have very opinionated ideas of how people should play should play wait Alex but I got a comment on my last playthrough that was like man people are really going crazy with the backseeing in this game it's me boy am I glad to see you me too I mean where am I hurrying can you lift me up what is this Doug!
My dad's up there somewhere.
I'm not holding area.
It's gonna take some doing to get him out.
Let's get out of here.
You're not alone.
We love you, Minto.
Thank you!
I wonder why Chad is done.
YouTube lost its entanglement with Chad.
I used to have a... I'm a father now.
Um, Alex.
I'm different.
Hi, Minto.
Hi!
Wait, what else is in here?
Anything?
You're going too fast.
I like to explore.
Okay, we're fine.
Every time I see these packages, I want to...
I want to... I think there's something in them.
It's a package.
Like, it just feels like there should be.
I'm afraid I'm flying blind here.
Every now and then a Vortigon gets captured and sends back information, but we don't have a complete picture of the place.
The little we do know is all bad.
All bad.
Get ready.
Oh.
Okay.
Alex, no!
Oh, that was good timing.
Holy cow.
Are you good?
Okay, I'm just shoving her.
I'm gonna save real quick.
She's in no rush.
Why is there graffiti in the...
Almost a graveyard in the jail?
Ooh, that doesn't look good.
Sorry, Gordon.
Oh, you're fine.
Not sure what to do.
All the head pads.
No, it's okay.
You don't have to donate.
That's definitely what you don't have to do.
But thank you.
Appreciate it very much.
All right.
Over here.
Is he in one of those pods?
See a cocoon?
Okay, you're hacking.
Let's go.
Love me a sexy...
lady hacker these poor people oh there papa all right i think i can bring him in wait is he gonna be a stalker you think oh no please papa to be a stalker there he's on the way thank you
Ha!
Done!
Okay.
Damn.
What if I...
Okay.
I won't get to where I am.
Holy cow!
Oh my god!
I didn't see that guy!
Where are we going?
Can I get some... I need some health!
Hold on!
Like, that's a... that's... that's one of those things from the other gun, no?
There he is!
Papa!
Which cocoon is- oh, that's- this is his cocoon?
Let me see if I can get this open.
Okay.
I don't want him to be a stalker.
Does I never play this game?
Can you say you're backseating me?
Jade Man is silencing us.
Is that really you?
I can't believe you found me.
Uh-huh!
Dad, are you alright?
you you've got to get out of here we're here to get you out dad never mind me save yourself no we're not leaving you I think I can recalibrate the combine portal to get us out of here where will you go I talked to dr. Kleiner his portal was almost working I can tell if he hasn't well it couldn't be any worse off it's not worth the risk Alex I can't lose you We're not leaving here without you.
That's final.
Ohana meets family.
Don't worry, Dad.
We'll find her.
For now, I'm going to send you to the teleport chamber.
Hey, thank you.
I'm not saying goodbye, Dad.
We'll meet you there.
I know you will.
I'll see you there, baby.
Bye-bye, Papa.
Look at him go!
Let's get out of here.
Okay.
Be careful.
There's gonna be guys.
Okay.
Right here.
I'm gonna head back to the security station and try to patch into your suit radio.
Wait.
Wait till you hear from me.
Hey, take care of yourself.
Oh, I'm going by myself?
Pay to play has been replaced by Pay to say i i'm sorry is it like hold on i'm gonna let me let me pause real quick let me if i is it just that like what were you saying about backseaters is it just is it i don't know
let me see live can you not chat either no it's broke broke wait test
Funny.
I think it's broke, broke.
Oh, well.
Sorry, guys.
Okay.
All right, Gordon, go on through.
Hold on, I'm going to go see for items.
Alex, you went so fast I didn't get to explore.
Okay, I'm not going to backtrack that much.
Okay, just kidding.
All right, let's go.
Go on, Gordon.
I'm going.
Woo!
Where's the other one?
Where's your friend?
They're so gross.
They kind of remind me of Daddy Long legs sometimes, though.
Oh.
Okay.
We got him.
Got
him.
Oh, sorry.
I turned up the volume a bit while they were talking.
Very good, very good.
Oh.
Hey, it worked.
Let's see what I can do to clear the way for you.
We didn't see this game.
Moss, man.
Wait, Moss, man.
Who died?
Whoa, I'm flying.
Who the heck is Moss, man?
I'm scared.
Even my test didn't show up.
Are you just watching me?
Oh.
Yes, please.
Okay, got it.
Thank you.
We're in the cleaner...
Oh, wait.
This is the, like, used part of the prison.
They got a sandwich and everything.
Moss, man.
Careful.
He'll make you phoneless.
Ah!
Thanks, I hate it.
I got her soda!
Okay.
Wait, no, no, no.
I want back to this.
Anything in there?
No.
In here?
So many fake little...
I'm sorry, you guys really don't have to donate.
It's okay.
I'll just keep talking to myself.
The yapping woman from earlier in the game who Alex doesn't like because she and her dad are flippant.
Oh, thank you!
Thank you, thank you.
I did forget.
Hello?
A guy?
Now what?
I didn't even see it.
Usually I feel like...
Usually I feel like I'm pretty observant about that kind of stuff.
Well, you guys would say otherwise but you guys can't talk right now so um that's all you can say
but i like the one needed to be though oh i feel bad so bad right now
oh gosh they're non-stop can i get through thank you
Ah!
And stuff.
Yeah, die right.
It's so...
Hot dog!
Otherwise.
Don't have to, though.
What?
Sorry, you're breaking up.
Why do I hear flies?
Hot dog!
I'm for one enjoying this new pay-to-chat experience.
No!
a lot of combine sensors in the area ahead what's combine oh oh oh head crab
thank you organizer youtube hates us specifically tonight is it just us are there other chats that are happening that are more exciting waiting?
Wait a second!
I see...
Ouch, I think I just took that damage, didn't I?
Ouch, ouch.
I don't think I backed up that.
This is a bad spot for me.
Lacerations detected.
Okay, I think that took care of some.
Yeah, we can go now.
I don't think there's any left.
I almost was not left.
I almost died too!
Wait, oh, those are turrets, aren't they?
Okay.
Keep remember.
Remember team, remember team.
But I also want the supply box, but there's one over here too.
Thank you.
Okay.
Hot dog.
Oh my gosh, you guys, thank you.
So sorry.
Soup.
Okay.
This does not look good.
I have a room.
Uh-oh.
Look at the monitor.
What?
Where are they?
Oh my gosh.
I didn't even see that.
Medical attention.
Holy cow, there's so many of them.
Wait, wait, wait.
Wait, what is this?
Oh, they are just giving me bots.
Oh, no, no, no, no.
This is unfair.
Wait.
I died.
Okay, hold on.
Okay, we're fine.
We're fine.
I know they give me grenades, so I know what to do.
Not bad.
Five.
G for grenade.
Any plans to play Alex?
Um, we'll see.
Head crab.
to the forehead.
Uh-oh.
Look at the monitor.
Okay.
I see.
Alright.
Hey!
No!
Oh my gosh!
I don't like this part at all.
There feels like too many men!
There's too many men!
Gosh.
I think I... Nope.
I won't be silenced.
Minto is cute.
Yeah, I said it.
This part.
Yucky.
Okay, hold on.
They give me so many grenades, but I'm not good at aiming it.
Look at the monitor.
I know.
It scares me, too.
Wait, I want to also.
I don't think that hit at all.
Oh, maybe it did.
Maybe it did.
I'm saving.
Oh, I was thinking halfway.
Maybe halfway?
I don't know.
I don't, I just said that.
You know what I mean.
Okay, maybe I actually got him this time.
Maybe I actually did it.
I can't tell.
It's so dark.
Okay.
Yeah.
Baby.
Okay.
Just like...
One scene in Joker 2.
Should we swap to waiting room chat?
It's working there?
Why?
Why does this hate me?
Why does YouTube hate me?
I don't think that would make a difference.
I think it would be...
I'd have to pull up a bunch of other stuff.
But honestly, I don't feel like doing it.
Thank you.
Ah.
Microtransaction is the hot new way to ramble by mail.
I don't know, but it's dead.
I don't know.
I did a test, and even that didn't go through on my end.
So I have no idea what the issue is.
I wish I could tell you guys.
The VOD watchers are probably like, oh my god, just shut up about it already.
I think I got one at least.
Yes, I got one.
Nice.
Is this thing on?
Thinking Swizzers and these guys are trying to kill you, Vito.
Oh, no.
Wait, ow, ow, ow.
Oh.
This is too high stress for me.
What was I thinking?
Oh, I'll go from relaxing game peak to...
high stress.
A still?
To a high stress half-life.
What was I thinking?
Live stream to a let's play.
It's true.
It does feel that way.
Okay, we finally took him down.
Finally took him down.
Downs.
Is this a room I can open?
Oh my gosh, stop.
I'm not trying to pick up everything in the world.
Okay.
Tonno chat is so it.
I hate this.
Hi
for me!
Oh.
Donkey Kong gameplay.
Nice barrel throws.
Why, thank you.
Did I get all of them?
What's this?
Okay, they want me to throw grenades in there, right?
Alright, I can do that.
Did that hit?
Maybe I need to, like, bounce it here.
Wait, did I just go into the room?
Maybe I need to bounce it here.
There we go, there we go!
So this works?
It does not!
I don't want it to just keep repeating and like, you know, what's the word?
I don't want it to just keep saying all the, my, whatever, uh, you know, the things.
The sounds.
A little don't know sounds over and over again.
Oh my gosh.
I almost did not see that.
Wait, this one's easy.
It's nice and close.
Okay, this is a little area.
I like the funny sounds.
Wait, let's go back to this.
No!
So unfair.
So unfair, you bastards!
Oops.
Oh my gosh, I'm gonna die here because I'm trying to do this.
I think there was health over there, though.
I remember.
Well, I say health.
I don't know what it is.
Oh my gosh, it's just one of these!
I wasted all of that.
I was so greedy for nothing.
New chatter here.
Am I doing this right?
I don't know, you guys.
I'm so sorry.
Shotgun Minky is kind of scary, you think?
Why?
Oh.
What was that?
Occupy them.
Why?
My
health though.
Oh no!
Oh, please say no.
Please don't say that.
Combat turrets.
These?
Yeah, yeah.
Okay.
Oh my gosh, we're doing a defense.
We're doing a... Oh gosh, wait.
Wait, but my health!
Okay.
Shotgun.
Until time.
No!
That's where they come from!
I didn't know which way...
Oh, I don't know why I thought from here.
I hear him.
Yeah, kill that guy!
Oh my gosh.
It's scary.
I don't...
I don't like this!
how long do i have to do this for i can't even i sorry guys i can't read your donos at the moment at all right now i'm so sorry i hear some
tower defense i played balloons i'm ready for this watch out for balloons
oh shoot uh shoot shoot shoot shoot
oh Mickey with a shotgun!
Mickey with a shotgun!
I wish I could have the turrets on my side.
Oh, all the time.
Moving so fast you can't see us all.
Call her cute.
No!
Chat's moving at so fast speed you can't see it moving at all.
It's moving so fast.
It's just in a constant state of single movement.
Wait, can I shoot from here?
Whoa, gosh.
I can.
Achievement to killing someone with a man hack.
Oh, really?
Be there in a second.
Oh, please, please hurry.
Oh my gosh, you almost landed on my head!
Sorry, it took me so long.
Yeah, you could say you kept him.
waiting let's see if we can find mossman it looks like this station ice monkey in the middle of the room there
she is oh no wait wait a minute how'd she attach to a turret i don't know how it feels in your area i'm not calling about that what's she up to you promised you weren't going to touch you like oh my god these soldiers were a bit overzealous i admit but he was too tempting a
You would have had Freeman if you'd been patient and dissuaded from my signal.
Ah!
We weren't entirely sure you were ever going to get around to that.
Human loyalties being what they are.
Dr. Br- Dr. Br- As I have seen it before, you have to let Eli come around on his own.
I have known Dr. Vance far longer than you, my dear.
I'm afraid your feelings- I'm afraid your feelings.
This is nothing to do with feelings.
It's a simple truth that when Eli believes in our...
This is not open to debate, Dr. Mossman.
Doctor, please...
So sorry, Judith.
I'm all out of time.
Damn her!
I don't believe this!
Come on, Gordon.
Now we've really gotta hurry.
Go on ahead.
I'll disrupt the next level of security and catch up with you when I can.
Wait!
Oh, man.
Wait.
Okay.
I guess I can collect all their stuff now.
Got anything?
I didn't drop.
Oh, I guess I'm full.
Go on, Gordon.
I'm...
Hold on!
Oh, there we go.
Seven!
We're containment seven!
Uh-oh!
Which way do I go?
Nope.
Seven!
That's me!
Okay.
This way!
Oh, the little pods.
Are there anybody in there?
No, they're empty.
I think this is the way I'm supposed to go.
Yes.
Maybe.
Oh wait, I don't know why.
We'll do this gun instead.
Spooky.
Any head crabs?
I don't like it, guys.
I don't like it.
It's getting dark.
Oh, hold on.
Let's let it reset.
Who are better?
Babies, turrets, or bugs?
The babies!
I actually really like the turrets too, though.
They did a good job.
I'm not gonna lie.
A dog!
This doesn't feel like a very hot dog moment.
Why do I feel like I'm back in ra- So sorry.
So sorry it's so loud.
Oh my gosh.
Why do I feel like I'm back in that horrible place?
I don't want to be there again.
Imagine doing a horror game without chat.
No, no, I don't want to imagine that.
What was it?
I don't like blowing them up because I don't know what I get.
I think I got health, I think.
I don't want to think about that.
I think I'm dependent on you guys.
Pinkies are proud creatures.
They prefer to give a look.
Oh, dead guy.
Oh, so definitely don't touch the water.
Wait, are we parkouring through water?
Oh, this is evil.
No, no, no.
Say it ain't so.
And then there's also...
Wait.
Say it ain't so!
Kind of what you're doing now, so no need to imagine.
I did save, right?
Oh my gosh, wait.
I hope I saved.
Okay, good.
She depends us.
On us.
I don't get it.
Imagine we are now the ghosts that are haunting you, and this is our spirit box.
This is hard.
Oh, no.
Wait, jump into the water.
I dare you.
He was...
Grabs are so cute the way they like kind of trot, though.
They're like...
You know what?
That's what they sound like to me.
In my head.
I think I depend on her too.
Look how cute he is.
Just walk it a lot.
Nah, never mind.
Oh, I didn't mean to do that.
This thing...
this guy doesn't seem like a good plan though to be what is that oh thank someone pooped in the pool
oh this is hard my health is already so low i think i'm just gonna need to use these two crates if i can you know you know I think I killed him.
Now he's dead.
Oh.
Who
donated us insom?
Who are you?
How old are you?
Alright, you forgot.
Are you French?
Ghostly wiggles in the lower right corner are way cuter than the crab ones.
No!
Okay.
Alright, we're taking this nice and easy.
Slow and steady.
Oh.
I think he got caught by the, uh...
By the electricity?
Just a hunch?
Oh!
Ouch!
Me too!
Ah!
Okay, wait.
I think it's way easier to go from up here.
Potentially.
Oh.
But I think I need to go with the crates so I can have them, I think.
Wait, what did I kill?
What did I shoot?
Wait, why did I have minor lacerations?
Why are we doing that?
Okay, hold on.
Let's just see what this way it takes me to.
You know?
You're a soup.
I'm a soup.
Can't handle a kid's these days are so soft.
Can't handle a little electrocution.
Back in my day, we walked to and from school ankle deep in toaster water.
I believe it, Grandpa.
Yeah, I feel like I need...
Wait, maybe I can grab them, though, over here.
Oh.
Guys, I didn't have the gravity gun.
Guys!
Okay, we have the gravity gun.
Oh, there he is.
Oh, where'd he go?
Okay, nice.
Oh, ouch!
That's alright.
It's alright.
He takes it.
Peak looks real different.
Yeah, it's a brand new update, actually.
It's really cool.
Don't break on me.
Okay, good enough.
Good enough.
Alright, and then...
Okay.
Very good.
Alright.
Okay.
Oh.
That was...
close not gonna lie i didn't think i was gonna make that not gonna lie i was pretty afraid not gonna lie
yahoo okay we take these even though i got hit by a head crab
i double shoot every single one of them i don't care
nice oh yeah baby Can I turn this off?
It's hurting me!
Um, F... F...
9.
There we go.
I'm not gonna waste that!
Okay.
Okay, don't get close.
I learned my lesson.
Way to conquer electricity.
Yes.
Call me...
The science guy.
Uh...
Call me...
Meantow.
How does a single barrel shotgun shoot double?
Explain that.
Like, don't even worry about it.
Like, don't even worry your pretty little head.
Oh.
Come to me.
Nice.
Oh.
Wait, I'm full of these, though.
Dang it.
But what if I use it right now?
And then I'll have another one.
On the ready.
Okay, here we go.
Okay.
Never mind.
Choo, thank you.
I hear that ghosts are extra cute when they are free men.
Looks like this is true.
Really?
Who told you?
Who told you that?
Coming!
You think they can see me here with my flashlight on?
You think he saw me?
TikTok, TikTok, TikTok.
I see them though.
That work?
TikTok, TikTok.
Can they shoot me through here?
Oh, they're trying.
Let's try like my pistol.
I don't think I can get through there.
I can, I can.
Let's go.
I lied.
I could shoot them for there.
Yep.
TikTok, TikTok.
Who?
Oh, I see you.
I see you.
Where'd you go?
I don't see you.
I see you.
I think I got him.
I hear movement anyway, though.
Alright.
Did I save?
There we go.
TikTok.
Another phrase for me to say over and over again, like, booty shot.
Booty shot.
That one's still the best, though.
I'll never leave my brain, I think.
Permanently.
Stuck saying night.
Okay.
Spooky.
I guess it doesn't matter which side I go to, huh?
They both connect.
Oh, wait.
Oh, there we go.
It's gonna say, can I?
I'm picking up more incoming soldiers.
See if there's some more turrets nearby.
Oh, no, no!
Please, really!
Okay.
Quick, get these set up.
I'm seeing soldiers in all directions.
What does that mean?
Where else should I put?
There's only three!
I heard?
Get them set up, she said.
Well, well, like, what?
Here they come?
Oh, gosh.
This sounds bad.
Holy.
Yeah, that's...
I'll take him out.
Wait, he's already out?
No freaking way.
I think I saved at a bad time.
More soldiers, okay.
Yeah, I didn't think that they were gone.
Oh gosh.
Am I gonna die here?
I'm gonna put you...
There.
This is bad.
Oh my gosh, you guys are back!
You live and I die.
Holy cow.
Wait, this is so difficult.
He already took them both out!
I can't lift them up!
No, no, no, I hate this.
Wait, I hate this so much.
Wait, I hate this.
I hate this!
How do I pick them up?
If I pick them up, they don't...
Oh, there it is.
Okay.
Where's my other guy?
That's not him.
There he is.
Please.
This is not good.
This is so bad, actually.
This is actually so bad.
Oh my gosh.
Please.
Why?
No, no, God, please.
Ah!
I'm gonna die.
Oh, wait, there's health here.
Let's win!
Ah!
Oh,
we are so back.
Welcome back, everybody.
That was so bizarre, huh?
This part is not fun.
Fun not, yeah.
This is the hardest room of the game for me.
Oh, ah.
They need to be facing correctly.
That's the one thing I can't tell what way they're supposed to be.
Oh, okay.
Good to know that there's a third round.
Okay, wait, hold on.
We can tell.
Okay, Toyo, thank you so much for the thank you for the thank you.
Hold on, I need to hydrate a little bit.
You guys survived.
You're the strongest.
You're the strongest here.
I was watching the whole time, but I still missed it.
Would you like some quality backseating, Minto?
Actually, yes.
Some quality backseating for this part.
actually starting to come back oh but i want to get through this before i quit because i don't want to start next stream with this part i woke up with a really really bad headache this morning
uh oh thank you for always every death you guys thank you test test you are doing it right this is a really hard room it feels like it it feels like it will be you can bunker down with turrets in a corner oh really okay i think i saved at a bad i saved at a bad spot though because they all start kind of like coming in already you know grab my guy here
wait this is kind of a good system wait this is kind of a good system
of a good system?
I don't know what he's shooting at.
Uh.
This
is kind of a good system?
I need to get rid of this guy.
Oh my gosh.
Wait.
Uh oh.
I wish I could grab that.
Oh!
No!
You ruined it!
Please stand up.
No.
Uh.
I don't know if this will work.
Oh my
gosh.
Oh, shoot.
Oh my gosh.
Wait, wait, wait.
I didn't even...
No!
Gosh!
Babies assemble.
Okay.
All right.
I saved it at a pretty bad spot, so they start coming in here immediately.
So I have to like, I have to get the turrets set up immediately.
It was a good strat, though, for a bit.
If only I was able to kill that guy faster, he wouldn't have thrown the grenade and then totally thrown my entire thing off.
Reload the last auto-save.
Actually, that's a good idea.
Let's see.
Auto-save.
It's a little sooner than this one.
Maybe we can.
Okay, hold on.
Let's try loading it.
Quick, get these set up.
I'm seeing soldiers in all directions.
Wait.
Oh, that's why.
I was like, hello.
Wait.
How do I turn you?
Turn, turn.
Oh, that's me.
Sorry.
Okay, like that, maybe is good.
Oh my gosh.
Wait, this is already bad.
Oh.
Get his ass!
Please, Tart!
There we go!
More soldiers.
I don't like this at all.
I don't like this one bit.
I hate this!
You are such a...
Bitch!
I
don't have much left.
I think.
No!
I'm
dead, I'm dead.
I resigned my fate.
Ah!
Yeah, maybe the corner strat is a little difficult.
But I can't keep them too far away.
It's hard.
Well, you can't keep them too far away because the soldiers will knock them out.
And so it's like you don't want to just be running around trying to, well, maybe that is the strat to just run in circles.
You're so rude, Alex!
There's a place above the cells to camp in.
Yeah, but how do I get three turrets up there?
How do I get three?
How do I get three turrets?
I'm just looking around real quick.
Okay, there's this, but I don't need it.
Maybe a room like this would be good.
Maybe this one?
Wait, this one had health too, no?
Yeah.
Oh, it does.
Try CQC.
I wish.
Kind of want to don't bunch them up for a single grenade.
knock everything out.
That's true, too.
That is so true.
I don't know what the best strat is for this, though.
Except survive.
Just live.
Naomi Hunter.
Wait, who isn't letting me super chat today?
Wait, I have to make a second account?
Oh my gosh.
Chimuru, wait, but you don't...
No!
Thank you, though.
I'm so sorry.
I'd make a second account to feel like you need to donate.
I don't know, guys.
I have no idea.
Sorry, my head is really starting to kill me, I think.
I don't want to stop here because this is such an annoying part that I will have to have to start up on.
But hey, this stream also started up on a pretty annoying part, too.
um,
You can't stop here.
I can if I'm not feeling well.
Ugh.
Might not be annoying if you don't have a headache.
That's true, too.
I think I'll be able to think more clearly if I am not in pain, you know?
So, let's do that.
Sorry, guys.
I'm not feeling so hot lately.
I want to play Delta a lot tomorrow, though.
I hope that I don't have a headache.
I don't want to be sick.
I have too much to do.
But I'm glad I could at least get in a little bit of half-life since I couldn't do it.
Since I couldn't do it yesterday.
Yes, yes, yes.
I'll take it easy after this then.
Um, so...
Uh...
And I'll see about tomorrow if I need to move Delta.
I hope not.
I wanted to play all day.
But thank you guys!
Thanks for the help with, uh...
With the stuff too.
Sorry again about the chat breaking.
Um, I'm gonna go rest.
And, uh...
Try not to throw up.
Oh.
Okay!
Thank you, everybody!
Thank you, thank you!
And I'll let you guys know about tomorrow as soon as possible.
More delta if it happens or not.
And, uh...
Oh god.
Hold on.
I don't have any more water.
Let me do this.
Okay.
Let me do a hard save.
Thank you everybody.
Bye-bye.
Sorry.